bonjour à vous Damien modèle merci
beaucoup d'avoir vous aussi accepté de
débattre et d'interpeller le ministre de
la Santé vous êtes député et les filles
vous avez choisi deux thèmes tout à
l'heure on vous parlerez de recaler
relocalisation des médicaments en France
c'est très important mais d'abord bon le
Ségur 1 faut-il un Ségur 2 c'est ça
votre préoccupation de toute évidence
mais j'aimerais commencer juste par une
citation la saturation des urgences
entraîne une vraie augmentation des
complications et de la mortalité et pas
aux urgences uniquement vous savez de
quel est cette citation peut-être de moi
parce qu'il y a déjà une étude dans ce
sens et sinon elle est reprise parce
qu'une étude de française
multicentrique et sortie il y a un mois
qui montre cette morbie mentalité
c'était d'ailleurs la suite d'études
internationales américaines et
canadienne qui ont montré la même chose
en effet la vôtre à l'époque vous aviez
mis en place un aubaine challenge pour
mesurer un obéchallenge donc en fait
c'était
président du syndicat SAMU urgence de
France pour savoir où est-ce qu'on
manquait de lit ou est-ce
la question aujourd'hui c'est que à
l'époque vous étiez donc syndicaliste et
vous mettiez ça en avant aujourd'hui
vous êtes ministre il y a des centaines
des dizaines des centaines de services
ou justement on a d'une saturation des
urgences des fois les urgences sont
fermés tout à l'heure j'entendais dire
que les urgences n'étaient pas fermées
honnêtement ce n'est pas vrai ce matin
encore j'avais des urgentistes qui
m'expliquaient que cet été ils allaient
fermer un service dites-moi ou parce que
là je peux je pourrais largement vous le
donner en Dordogne il y a les urgences
qui sont fermées la nuit par exemple on
pourrait aussi on pourrait citer aussi à
Rouen où il y a des difficultés ça
s'inter service on pourrait citer je
crois que c'est l'hôpital attendez mais
si vous voulez que je vous désirez
un sacré paquet un sacré paquet
d'exemple de service attendez je vais
vous retrouver la différence et j'ai
expliqué tout à l'heure entre fermeture
et accès réguler c'est pas du tout la
même chose alors attendez alors sur les
sur les exemples les urgences de
l'hôpital de Saint-Flour ferment
plusieurs nuits les urgences de
Fontenay-le-Comte ferme plusieurs nuits
les urgences du centre hospitalier de
centre Bretagne ferme plusieurs nuits
les urgences de Brioude ferment plus
ennuis la maternité de Péronne ça c'est
la maternité qui ferme ses portes de ce
mois les urgences de sarlats qui ont
fermé plusieurs jours et plusieurs nuits
qui étaient en accéléré
ferme plusieurs nuits on a les urgences
de Luçon qui ferment plusieurs nuits on
a l'urgence de Lannion qui ferme
plusieurs nuits on a les urgences de
Saint-Nazaire qui vont faire mieux cet
été
mais déjà dans quelques exemples que
vous avez cités des urgences qui sont en
accès régulier je vais vous je pourrais
vous la donner aujourd'hui on a décidé
on a des services qui sont saturés mais
encore ce matin j'avais un urgentiste
qui m'expliquait que quand il a pris son
service donc il y a deux jours il y
avait 45 personnes qui étaient qui
étaient dans les urgences et donc
c'était pas c'était pas de la boboologie
c'est des gens qui étaient dans les
urgences parce qu'il fallait les garder
en observation il y en avait 12 qui
étaient là depuis plus de 24 heures et
donc certains qui étaient là même depuis
4 jours aujourd'hui moi ce qui ce qui
m'attriste c'est qu'en vérité vous étiez
prise en charge
parce que il y avait pas de leaderval il
y avait pas de
souciations qui étaient aussi fermées
notamment dans certains services
aujourd'hui on voit ça moi je vois vous
qui était qui était syndicaliste et je
me demande comment ça ça ne peut pas
vous alerter j'ai le sentiment de plus
en plus
montrer quoi et je les fais j'ai signé
il y a un peu plus d'une semaine on gère
les lits non plus à l'échelle du seul
établissement qui a son service
d'urgence mais à l'échelle de tous les
établissements du secteur c'est pas
quelque chose d'extraordinaire c'est ce
qu'on a fait pendant le covid c'est ce
qui nous a permis partout et j'étais sur
le terrain je sais je l'ai fait c'est ce
qui nous a permis de tenir pendant le
covid et on fait pareil maintenant on
responsabilise cette prise en charge des
patients
urgent non programmés sur l'ensemble
d'un territoire et puis seulement sur un
établissement et bien ça ça permet déjà
d'améliorer les choses et c'est fait
très largement région PACA avec une
gestion qui est un peu plus large de
l'ensemble des lits disponibles donc oui
il y a des solutions oui je mets en
application des solutions maintenant si
la solution c'est de dire il faut
rouvrir des lits bien sûr bien sûr je ne
demande que ça mais pour ça faut des
professionnels c'est pas le tout d'avoir
des lignes mais des patients dans des
glisses en personne pour les surveiller
s'il y a personne pour les plans pour
recruter les professionnels aujourd'hui
il y a 70% de vendre des infirmières
donc c'est une catégorie qui dit
qu'elles ne sont pas satisfaites par les
mesures du gouvernement et que ça ne
suffit pas et vous le savez que ça ne
suffit pas alors et aujourd'hui on a
l'impression qu'on pourra pas aller plus
ça ne suffit pas peut-être en tout cas
il y a eu des augmentations conséquentes
par le Ségur il y a une augmentation
encore récemment annoncée du point
d'indice donc il y a une amélioration
des conditions j'ai doublé les
indemnités de nuit pour le personnel non
médical nous formons nous rajoutons 6000
infirmières qui sont formées la
formation d'infirmière et la formation
qui est la plus demandée dans parcoursup
c'est une formation qui est une vraie
montée dans l'échelle sociale que 50%
des gens qui vont dans cette formation
sont des gens qui font partie des non
absolument
oui vous avez même qu'au bout de trois
ans tout un tas d'infirmières
abandonnent d'ailleurs vous l'avez dit
même avant vous et c'est ça la vraie
problématique non mais laissez-moi finir
parce que ça c'est important vous dites
les gens abandonnent oui il y en a 10 %
qui abandonnent la première année ça
c'est un véritable problème et on fait
quoi pour ça je suis en train de
réformer complètement la formation et le
métier d'infirmière et ça avec la
satisfaction de tous les représentants
des infirmières il faut changer ce
métier qui n'a pas évolué depuis 2004 si
on ne fait plus l'exercice infirmier de
la même façon les infirmières ont plus
de responsabilités et le travail main
dans la main avec les médecins et les
autres professionnels on développe les
infirmières en pratique avancées donc
oui il y a beaucoup de choses qui se
font pour les infirmières mais vous
savez comme moi que le système de santé
ne se réorforme pas en claquant des
doigts ni en deux mois il faut du temps
mais le sentiment qu'on a aujourd'hui
c'est surtout qu'on ne voit pas
l'objectif
quel est votre proposition alors
qu'est-ce qu'on voudrait parvenir par
ailleurs plusieurs propositions quand on
avait fait un rapport qui s'appelait
allo Segur monsieur le Nice donc ne
dites pas que nous n'avons rien proposé
il y a d'autres groupes notamment avec
la Fondation Jean Jaurès qui ont fait
des propositions seulement aujourd'hui
moi je pense pense qu'il faudrait partir
par exemple d'une augmentation des
salaires drastiques non pas parce que
c'est la seule chose qui est demandé
mais c'est attirer avec
l'attractivité avec ses salaires mais
après derrière il faut aussi mettre
certaines choses en place je pense que
la question des ratios n'est pas évincée
aussi facilement d'avoir un certain
nombre
aussi posé cette question là il y a la
question de la pénibilité derrière à
prendre en compte mais je pense
honnêtement qu'avec les 183 € du Ségur
et on le voit bien que ça ne suffit pas
c'est que depuis le figure de la santé
il y a pas eu une croissance énorme de
personnes qui viennent travailler à
l'hôpital c'est tout l'inverse je pense
sentiment c'est qu'on ne va pas faire le
mieux aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez
le sentiment des gens vous disent on va
aller vers le mieux pour l'hôpital
personne ne sera un par vous et c'est
bien ça vous voyez bien quand vous êtes
parce que justement je me déplace
beaucoup et dans beaucoup d'endroits y
compris des endroits où ça ne va pas
bien vous dites les gens il y a un
problème d'attractivité à l'hôpital oui
mais bien entendu je suis tout à fait
d'accord et quand je discute avec les
personnels ce n'est pas qu'un problème
de salaire c'est un problème de
condition de travail c'est pour ça que
là je mène la réforme pour revenir à
l'échelle du service à une échelle
humaine dans l'hôpital et non pas ses
grands pôles Gigantes est-ce que les
gens ne se retrouvent plus c'est pour ça
que on diminue tout ce qui n'est pas de
l'activité de soins que ce soit en ville
comme à l'hôpital d'ailleurs donc il y a
beaucoup de choses à faire autour de ça
c'est pour ça que je réforme
complètement ce métier d'infirmière qui
a d'autres objectifs maintenant qui ne
s'exercent plus de la même façon oui il
y a des choses à faire pour l'hôpital
vous parliez des ratiaux je vais revenir
sur cette notion de ratio est-ce que ça
c'est là vous êtes entre vous là c'est
quoi les ratio
temps de patients il faut tant
d'infirmière alors moi je suis pas tout
à fait d'accord ce principe de ratio
vous avez raison je dis qu'il faut le
nombre de personnel en lien avec la
charge en soins ça veut dire quoi c'est
une équivalence de ratio mais ça je
connais bien l'hôpital j'ai travaillé 38
ans vous disiez vous pouvez avoir deux
services de médecine vous avez un
service de médecine ou le médecin une
orientation plutôt de maladies un peu
rares ou de rhumatologie par exemple
avec plutôt des patients jeunes et
plutôt des durées de séjour courtes et
vous avez le même service étiqueté
médecine avec des patients plutôt de 70
et des durées longues et des patients
qui sont dépendants et bien mettre un
ratio identique pour tout ce qui
s'appelle service de médecine c'est une
erreur par contre dire que on évalue la
charge en soins et nous avons des outils
d'évaluation de la charge en soi
unique pour tous les services ça c'est
trop bien
sur les financements moi j'ai du mal à
croire aujourd'hui qu'on pourra faire
mieux sur l'hôpital public avec moins
d'argent aujourd'hui la Fédération
hospitalière de France disent qu'il a il
leur manque entre 1,5 et 2 milliards
d'euros ne serait-ce que pour compenser
l'inflation on a Bruno Le Maire qui nous
fait des menaces sur le fait qu'ils vont
aujourd'hui sacrifier une partie du
budget de la santé vous savez que c'est
vrai que le pffss n'est pas la hauteur
même monsieur mix on sait même croisé un
moment donné je vous ai demandé le
budget ça ne va pas vous m'avez dit non
ça ne va pas aujourd'hui vous le voyez
bien qu'on manque de finance et c'est
impossible de faire croire aux gens
qu'on va faire mieux avec moins d'argent
mais j'ai pas dit qu'on ferait mieux
avec mien en tout cas je l'ai je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure on en a parlé que si
les économies doit y avoir c'est des
économies qui ont un sens en terme de
santé publique et je donnais l'exemple
de la trop de prescription
d'antibiotiques donc en tout cas moi je
ferai pas de coupe sur l'hôpital aveugle
financière ça c'est d'un autre temps
maintenant nous sommes dans une logique
où on met en avant la prévention ou au
moins en avant la réponse aux besoins de
la population et c'est dans ce sens-là
que je vais
sur la question des relocalisations
alors enchaînons sur la question des
relocalisations il y a eu un rapport qui
est sorti vous l'avez sans doute vu au
Sénat aujourd'hui deux questions simples
est-ce que la France doit produire une
partie de ces médicaments nous on pense
qu'il faut que la France produise une
partie de ces médicaments notamment ceux
qui ont été en pénurie ça peut être le
cas de l'amoxine et la France au sens
que l'État se prenne en charge c'est
cette dimension là et l'autre point
c'est la conditionnalité des aides moi
je suis à la commission des finances je
vois que nous donnons des crédits
d'impôts à tout va notamment il y a le
crédit d'impôt recherche dont on
pourrait parler et à des groupes qui des
fois supprime la moitié de leurs
effectifs de recherche aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il faut une
conditionnalité des aides sur la
relocalisation parce qu'on a eu la liste
on a le sentiment qui a rien de
contraignant et qu'elle pourrait partir
du jour au lendemain alors il y a il y a
un enjeu majeur et je vous rejoins sur
la lutte contre les pénuries d'une façon
très générale c'est un enjeu qui n'est
pas que français vous le savez c'est un
enjeu qui pour le coup l'international
c'était l'objet de la dernière
discussion avec mes homologues européens
il y a un mois et demi c'était
entièrement sur cette pénurie médicament
dans les réponses à la pénurie de
médicaments il y a plusieurs plusieurs
des éléments et d'ailleurs c'est le plan
pénurie que je porte avec la définition
de cette liste médicaments essentiels
j'ai été à la commission des affaires
sociales du Sénat j'aurais expliqué la
façon dont cette liste avait été faite
et ils sont tout à fait satisfaits de
moins en rapport oui mais le rapport est
sorti le matin même et j'étais reçu
l'après-midi donc réécoutez-moi au Sénat
vous aurez l'explication qui convient le
président de la République c'est c'est
engagé dans le cadre de la de France
2030 à relocalisé de la production de
médicaments 25 molécules qui vont être
localisées en France il y a la
relocalisation en France il y a la
relocalisation en Europe et d'ailleurs
la France soutient un projet belge et on
n'est pas allé seul à le soutenir on est
une vingtaine de pays déjà à le soutenir
sur la relocalisation entre autres la
relocalisation en Europe d'un certain
production de médicaments
et en France bien entendu mais vous
parlez de l'amoxicilline amoxicine est
produite en Europe donc le problème de
la pénurie que nous avons eu
d'amoxicilline très bien doublé des
productions il est pas il est pas il est
pas lié uniquement un problème de
production il est lié aussi un problème
de mauvais anticipation de la
consommation et une explosion de la
consommation en poste covid ah ça c'est
vrai que vous avez je pense mal anticipé
pour le coup sur la question de la
condition humaine
anticipé sur les industriels qui ont
prévu leur production sur les chiffres
de l'année précédente et donc et on
était en plein covid et on avait des
nouvelles et bien justement sur la
question des aides sur la condition
c'est le principe de cette liste des
médicaments essentiels de voir une
cartographie de l'ensemble de la
production d'imposer aux industriels des
contraintes il y en a déjà vous le savez
très bien sur la liste des 3000
médicaments on a des contraintes de
stock qui vont de 1 mois à trois mois en
fonction des types de médicaments sur
l'homologation ou l'autorisation de mise
sur le marché non c'est des contraintes
qui sont liées simplement au fait que on
paye les médicaments pour qu'il soit sur
le marché français et sur la
conditionnalité des aides aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'une entreprise qui touche des
aides est-ce qu'elle pourra les toucher
mais ensuite tout de même supprimer les
postes de chercheurs et délocaliser
Sanofi durant le covid à tous les 200
millions d'euros une semaine après ils
ont supprimé 1000 postes est-ce que ça
ce sera encore possible ce sera la
dernière réponse
ça fait partie des choses à discuter
comme j'ai dit il y a pas de tabou et
tout doit être mis sur la table pour que
les Français n'aient plus cette pénurie
de médicaments
il y a des discussions actuelles je vais
pas je vais pas faire des conclusions
avant le groupe de travail qui est
impossible de dire si on donne de
l'argent ils doivent faire des respecter
dans ce sujet dans ce sujet précis des
relations et du prix de médicaments avec
les industriels la première ministre a
mis en place un groupe de travail qu'on
doit de Novartis
de l'industrie c'est pas parce qu'ils
sont aussi un industrie
jamais conclusion pour me positionner
ils vont donner leur conclusion et en
fonction de leur conclusion je me
positionne sur ce qui doit être de la
part d'un groupe d'experts composés
majoritairement de gens de l'industrie
pharmaceutique de réguler l'industrie
pharmaceutiques
sur la liste des 450 médicaments que on
ne sait pas d'où viennent les
professionnels
qui viennent des sociétés savantes je
crois qu'il y a un moment donné il faut
arrêter de toujours pas d'affirmation
sur la régulation des aides pas de
négation non plus
donc ça ça veut dire qu'il y aura rien
enfin on connaît
je sais qu'on a l'habitude de prendre
des décisions mais on crée un groupe de
travail de spécialistes on leur demande
un avis la moindre des choses c'est
d'attendre leur avis vous êtes déçu par
la réponse
de la langue merci en tout cas d'avoir
été avec